Vernon Smith received the 2000 to
Nobel Memorial Prize in Economic
Sciences for his pioneering work
in experimental economics.
I caught up with the 96 year old
recently in Southern California
and conducted a long interview about
his life and work that will appear
as a Reason podcast.
Here's part of our conversation
about Joe Biden's massive $6.8
trillion budget plan, the role
of government spending and Federal
Reserve policy in causing inflation,
the bailout of Silicon Valley Bank
and why Smith believes it's
very hard to keep Democrats
from wanting to make the world
better by spending other
people's money.
Vernon Smith, thanks for talking to
Reason.
Nick, it's great to be here.
Over the past
four or five years, starting
under Donald Trump, but the federal
government has just pumped tons
of money into circulation.
Joe Biden recently proposed
a $6.8 trillion budget.
You know, we're experiencing
inflation.
What is the way out of that
kind of situation?
Well, I
think, the first way out
is for the central bank not to
accommodate spendthrifts
and government.
Because it's
very hard to keep Democrats wanting
to make the world better by spending
other people's money.
You know, they're really committed
to that. And the Republicans, to
some extent, they could
screw up, you're not going to be
saved necessarily by them.
But the central bank, you see,
they are taking, I
think, more seriously than they have
to their so-called fiduciary
responsibility to the government.
They don't have to accommodate that.
You see, when when
Joe Biden decided to write
$600 checks per month
for all kinds of people
who were sitting at home and not
producing any goods because
of COVID, well, that's not, you
you can't stimulus, they call it
stimulus, there's nothing to
stimulate.
It's, it's, it would
be like during the Second World War
having a stimulus, while you didn't
need it, you needed the reverse.
And so you know, that's going to be
inflationary.
And, and, of course,
the Fed fully accommodated
that, whatever of that
debt wouldn't be held by private
citizens. They, they
bought enough from existing
private citizens that they were
willing to buy the new debt.
Right.
You know, the Federal Reserve
is not supposed to buy it directly,
but it's a thing.
And moreover, they buy,
interestingly, they buy
that debt for the account of
Treasury. That's called
neutralization.
They discovered that in October 2008
that, oh, wait a minute, that's the
way to do it. You don't buy it
and hold on in the bank because that
gives the central bank,
because all of the banks have
increased reserve deposits and
they will expand credit.
So you just transfer it
to the Treasury,
it's really a Treasury on this hill.
It's like, it's as though
your, your banker told you,
Nick, go and spend whatever
you want to, if you don't have
enough income about will
float bonds to cover
that and we'll hold them in
your town and our bank.
Yeah.
So that's what the federal
government—so there's no budget
constraint.
Right.
None on
the government.
So recently the,
I mean, the Federal Reserve did
start raising the interest
rate and
that had the effect, you know,
the standard narrative
of the reason why Silicon Valley
Bank and Signature Bank...
Yes.
...you know had a run on them was
because, you know, the
Fed hiked interest rates and
suddenly the long term bets that
these banks have made made
no sense.
And people were pulling money out.
They were.
So is the Fed starting to do
its job?
Well.
In my view, it didn't do its job
before, and that's the way we got
the problem now?
Yeah.
It's doing what it always does.
If there's inflation, you'll see,
it starts to...
But those inflations are
typically coming
from excessive government spending
that's accommodated by the central
bank in the first place.
That's where we get inflation.
You see, it's not coming from
people.
It's coming from government.
The big stimulus for the
inflation came when people were
not home, not producing goods
because of COVID.
And then they stimulated the
economy. Well, there's no more
goods.
Yeah.
So the prices basically have to go
up. It's just, you know,
it's just arithmetic.
And, and, well, what
I predicted at the time was
that we would have a one time
increase in prices.
It would continue only
if the government continued to do
the deficit finance.
In other words now, and
I don't trust them not to do that,
you see. And the problem with
inflation, you see, everything
that the Democrats are trying to do
to help the disadvantaged and the
poor is all taken
back because those are the groups
that are so severely hit by
inflation.
So you're saying when the governor
of California gives you, you
know, $100 so that you can
afford gas,
that now cost more money, you're
you're generally not making out too
well.
That's right. Yeah.
Do you think...
Silicon Valley Bank,
you know, almost immediately when
the run on it happened,
the government the federal
government said, don't worry, we're
going to cover all deposits.
We're, you know, we're gonna...
Is that a good idea or is that, is
that a good rule or a bad role?
You got to think of the
consequences.
You're taking all risk
out of bank deposits.
Bank deposits
are the source of investment funds
of the banks.
So they're the source of capital
they don't have to worry about.
It's just really, you know,
that they don't have to worry about
the default on that.
The government will take care of it.
And that and to me, that invites
banks to not worry very much about
doing extremely risky investments.
And, ah,
well, there's a lot of,
you know, risky,
potentially high-innovation
activities that you'd
like to see capital go to.
But someone's got to make a judgment
because there's lots of those
alternatives and
most of them are going to go under.
So there's a room here for some
skill in investing.
And if you take all of that
risk out of it, I think that's
extremely dangerous.
Do you worry that it's, I mean,
right now it's, you know, to,
you know, Silicon Valley Bank gets
bailed out.
We weren't supposed to do this
anymore. Right. Because back during
the financial crisis.
Yeah, we...
We figured that out and we came up
with a new regulation so no bank
would need that.
Are you worried that it's you know,
this is just a continuation of
bailing out failure?
Well, yes, and of course
the really big mistake before was
to bail out bank equity
holders.
The presumption was that we
were, or the
thought was, and I think
the government wanted people
to believe, that we were bailing out
depositors, but they did more than
that because
depositors,
you see, are protected by two
things: insurance,
prepaid insurance of the banks,
plus the equity in the bank.
That's what is available to cover
as a cushion to
the cover deposit laws.
And every bank needs
to take that risk into account.
Otherwise it won't get shareholders.
They won't buy the common stock.
You see, unless there's a reason
that risk is, is not too
large.
And if you take all that out, I
think there's no equilibrium.
I don't I don't know how that world
would even work.